and then you fast forward a little bit
further i think it was 1996 or 1997. it
was 1997.
and now i meet the hulk again now only
now he's the admiral he's in charge of
all the seals
and he interviewed me
and wrote me a recommendation to become
a seal officer
and i got accepted into that program
and carried on with the rest of my
career
but never forgot the impression that
admiral richards left on me
and on the seal community and it's an
honor to have him here tonight to share
some of his experiences some of his
stories some of his lessons learned from
a 30-year career
in the seal teams
admiral
thanks for coming by
well jocko thanks for having me here uh
when i sit here and listen to uh those
excerpts from michael slattery's article
that
takes me back to those rice paddies
and
it is a day that i would have to
describe as
one of the worst days in my entire naval
career it had to be the worst
day but also tell you it was the best
[__] day
cause i got those guys
i got those guys
out of the kill zone
over to the protection of the dyke
and then into the helo
yeah i was a big strong guy
there's something called uh adrenaline
rush adrenaline high and all that other
stuff and you know maybe you could uh
you help some you know you know limp
dick uh you know pencil neck geek uh you
drag some of those guys across the rice
paddy but i seriously effing doubt it
um
thankfully it was me who was only
wounded in one hand
and i was able to drag those guys out of
there
listening to
carl nelson
make those
gun runs
i don't know if there's any car nuts in
the room or listening in here but
one of my roommates at villanova had a
1967 corvette 427 425 dam horsepower
and when skip stood on that thing
i believe he had a couple of cutouts
legal or not but when skip stood on that
sucker
it roared well
that is the closest sound that i can
describe to those who haven't been there
when a minigun rips off and lights off
and that was one of the most beautiful
sounds that i've ever heard
so
as i'm
going back and forth uh
grant telfer and his uh uh
his update to the uh to the award
recommendation uh you know use those
terms that you used in the article
without regard to
my own personal safety or my life
i have to tell you that i never gave a
thought
to anything
but my teammates
who were
grant was shot in both legs uh
rock jim roland uh
shot
in the chest and the groin
and of course
jim's major concern with those injuries
was
would the equipment ever work again
uh
and then uh you know you you mentioned
how uh
don futrell was getting ready to go into
shock uh
you know
i'd never been trained about what
somebody going into shock sounds like or
doesn't uh i had no clue but as soon as
i heard don
and uh you know you could hear his voice
going up a few octaves uh he referred to
it and
a note to me about his girly voice hey
don you were just shot in the damn chest
uh and uh you you got a right to be you
know you know going into panic or
whatever it is i didn't we didn't have
that conversation this is flashing
through my mind uh but uh i could hear
it and i just said you know it just came
to me get his mind off his situation and
get it back on to our situation uh
i didn't realize how badly he was
injured and that he was going to be
useless as tits on a boar hog after that
but you know i just wanted to get him
back into action
uh and and out of out of any shock
because you know we're we're in the
middle of nowhere and uh i have no idea
how if we're even gonna get out of there
and if we get out of there how long it's
gonna take and so on and so forth so uh
you know just the uh
the great training from the
legends and seal team one before i got
there you know that we used to call it
seal basic indoctrination training and
then we'd go through a pre-deployment uh
training program but uh those uh who
set the history of seal team one before
i got there
those guys
made all the uh made all the difference
in the training and my reaction and
everybody else's reaction in the in the
rice paddy so as i was saying it was the
best of days and it was the worst of
days uh you know thank god everybody got
out of there uh
i don't know how often it happens but
i'm willing to bet not very often both
roland and futrell when they were shot
in the chest
the bullets passed front to back
didn't touch a bone you just went
through soft tissue and the uh the heat
of the round actually uh cauterized the
uh cauterized injury uh those guys you
know who are you know
goddamn lucky is is all i can say of
course i didn't know that at the time uh
and uh
you know it was just uh just a real uh a
real
uh crappy situation